this has gone to the most powerful wings
of government arguably in Washington DC
now deliberately fabricating or
misleading investigations for reasons of
political expediency it is terrifying
has this all confirmed the idea of the
deep state if you've been following an
impeachment okay let's start with us
this week the Justice Department the
inspector Justice Department inspector
the Justice Department inspector general
sorry Michael Horowitz so many vowels
lots of titles what's going on release a
report looking in the FBI's
investigation of President Trump's
campaign okay he was questioned about
the report in a Senate hearing yesterday
let's see that real quick the inspector
general found that when the FBI secretly
opened an investigation into possible
Russian influence of the Trump campaign
in July 2016 it followed the launching
that kind of case the report says the
FBI's court application made statements
about Steele that were quote inaccurate
incomplete and unsupported over selling
his value as a source and glossing over
the fact that many claims he made were
not checking out yeah
claims some mistakes that's a funny word
if you listen to some of the leftist
shows and I've been listening to
obviously the Young Turks pod save
America or reading up at Vox and so on
they're gonna try and spin this as some
minor procedural errors made by
low-level FBI employees that's kind of
the story that's been going out there
and I encourage you to go and read and
watch further left sources because that
is kind of a narrative that they've said
just sound familiar to anybody when
conservatives were targeted by the IRS
so it's low-level people it was a
mistake right we didn't do this which by
the way also lends itself to the fact
that civil libertarians and a lot of
Republicans always had a problem with
the abuses of FISA right we've if you
could if you could search out if we
could search which words we've used in
this program we've talked about barack
obama and Phi's up several times like i
do think it's important to be consistent
here let's go through the series of
mistakes the FBI made even if maybe the
inspector in general can't detect any
pattern that might point to a motive
maybe we can so we would like to
introduce this new segment a calls could
it all be an accident
[Applause]
boy that was out of tenants oh really I
will take conspiracy theories for 500
and ensuring that I am removed from the
platform okay let's start with this this
there's a couple of claims let's go
through the claims what are the claims
that Comey and others were exonerated
Democrats left-wing media they were
quick to say that the IG report
exonerated James Comey
right we have an overlay here the truth
is that the Inspector General said the
report did nothing even close to that
the former FBI director James Comey said
this week and that your report
vindicates him is that a fair assessment
of your report I you know I think the
activities we found here don't indicate
anybody who touched this yeah no they
have a problem with reports here what's
going on like the bar thing with no
collusion there no they didn't say that
and this didn't say something and
they're saying it says something well or
the believed bar is an example of
collusion at the corruption at the
highest level as opposed to dozens of
high-level employees at the FBI who
systematically worked to undermine our
presidency just be just be sure that you
understand yeah just one have it
straight I want to make sure thank you
another claim which i think is you guys
may remember this but there were a lot
of claims made and it's kind of silly
that we have to go back to this but this
is actually very important because of I
don't know if this is effectively
falsified we'll get some information
that to me I'm not I'm not a lawyer we
have a lawyer seems falsified but the
context of this seems at the very least
deliberately misleading some claims that
people made regarding the infamous
Russian peeing tape oh boy when you told
him the contents of the steel dossier
did you get the impression it was the
first time we'd ever heard those
allegations yes and I didn't give him
the briefing on the whole steel dossier
my assignment was to brief him on a
small part of it that was salacious and
personal and my sense was I didn't get a
sense that he knew about those why
include that salacious part if it was
something that you thought was you know
not that necessary to the investigation
or did you think it was important that
he knew we thought it was important that
he knew and I say we meaning all the
intelligence Chiefs that put together
the intelligence community assessment we
thought it was
that he know because we knew and we
don't be holding that back from the new
president and you believe his denial
honestly never thought these words would
come out of my mouth but I don't know
whether the current president itíd
States which was prostitutes peeing on
each other Moscow 2013 it's possible but
I don't know and by the way after that
interview Chuck Todd's goatee cocooned
into a butterfly and flew away
[Laughter]
summarizer Comey was saying that was his
duty to brief the president about the P
tape and then claims that it very he
thought it very well may have been true
let me explain this very clearly the FBI
not only knew that the story had zero
corroboration they knew that it was in
fact a joke the FBI interviewed Steele
source and asked him to corroborate the
story but the source and I have a quote
here explained that his or her
information came from word-of-mouth and
hearsay
another quote conversation that he or
she had with friends over beers and that
some of the information such as
allegations about Trump's sexual
activities were statements he or she
heard made in Jess oh my gosh think of
that for a second all you needed to do
was make a joke and if it were front if
it reflected badly enough on President
Trump the FBI would purposefully
misrepresent it as though it was a
credible allegation all the way up to
the director of the entire FBI who would
then brief the President himself on it
the more information that comes out the
worse it is for Democrats that is a
consistent through linear examples it is
we've often said like there's probably a
kernel of truth to it I thought maybe
there were Russian prostitutes peeing in
a Trump Hotel and he knew about it and
said you know they like the waters would
something like that turns out there is
no kernel of truth at all it was
entirely made up from a joke the truth
is worse than the willing I'd say
scraping the bottom of the barrel but
it's a bottomless barrel you're just
like your your way down into the dirt
and you're looking up goes up another
play that they make the steal dossier
wasn't central to the FISA warrant oh no
it's right before that I need to tell
people right hit the notification bail
because subscriptions don't mean a whole
lot but do subscribe to the channel we
have a new video you've been letting me
say this wrong this whole
it's 9:00 Eastern it's not Eastern Time
it doesn't matter either way
join up at my club bladder with hunter
comms flash mug Club that's where you
get all of the extra content some shows
even hosted by me half a similar bill
Richmond where's the whole blaze catalog
and next week Wednesday big live
Christmas show it'll be a live stream
with a discount we'll be raising money
for Christmas baskets ok let's move on
here another claim this is important
because you're gonna hear this from the
young turks are going to hear this from
all these left sources MSNBC that the
steel dossier wasn't central to the FISA
warrant okay in case you've forgotten
maybe you recall that Devon Nunez the
memo claims the steel dossier was an
essential part of the evidence used to
begin the FBI spying on Trump's campaign
the Democrats claimed that this was
absolutely not true the deputy director
of the FBI
McCabe testified before your committee
in December of 2017 that no surveillance
warrant no FISA Court to this visor
court would have been sought without the
steel dossier information is that true
that's a not what the director became a
cave actually said well I can't go into
the details of what he said essentially
his argument was we look at this as a
complete hole all the parts of the
application are important okay so of
course the entire leftist made they
piled on as well claiming a sealed
dossier was only a small part of the
evidence death definitely not essential
non-essential
it's funny here's the truth not only to
the IG report find that the dossier
played a cent I want to read this as a
quote central and people going oh you
can't get it today I am making sure that
I am on this iPad because I don't want
to get this wrong do it when you're
dealing with the FBI kind of can do
anything they want they can make the
mistakes not you found the dossier
played a central and essential role in
the FISA application when it came to
Carter pages by the way alleged Russia
collusion the steel dossier was the
entire basis it was it wasn't a small
basis it wasn't a portion it was the
only basis here's another claim that the
Obama administration didn't use a
dossier to all this this came out this
week that they didn't use the dossier at
all in their intelligence assessment
here you go listen to them do you know
if the bureau ever relied on the steel
dossier as any as part of any court
filings I like anybody very shiny
petition
bleeding I have no awareness at all
complete utterly unaware did the CIA
rely on it
no one IO because we we did it wasn't
part of the corpus of intelligence
information that we had it was not in
any way used as a basis for the
intelliscan me assessment that was done
it was it was not and by the way that
they didn't rot out Gerald Ford's corpse
that CIA director John Brennan in case
you didn't know and he was saying that
they didn't even know about the Steele
dossier right the Obama ministration
this is important to know they all knew
about the Steele dossier it was actually
included as an appendix in the
assessment itself not only do they give
the steel dossier credit he practically
wrote the foreword even further than
that by the way Comey and McCabe fought
to have it playing even more central
role in the assessment proactively so I
want to be clear I mean I don't know at
what point lying yeah yeah constitutes a
crime yeah but this I want you to
research the sources for yourself okay
we have to we got a cycle through this
because we have Tim Poole coming up
pretty quick to talk about anonymity
policies here's another claim they make
up a FISA warrant was obtained
completely honestly on the up Annamma a
total confidence that the FISA process
was followed and that the entire case
was handled in a thoughtful responsible
way by DOJ and the FBI I think the
notion that Pfizer was abused here is
nonsense
okay so this is pretty important and and
let me know if it's a little confusing
and maybe Bill you can help clarify
because it's confusing for me sometimes
and I work in this industry
the FBI created fraudulent evidence to
obtain the one I know because I won't
care because I'm making a claim here I
believe that I can make that claim and
substantiate it just pause or if you
don't have the time fast forward four
seconds Carter page K was actually
acting as an informant for the CIA
during these Russian meetings okay the
FBI knew that right so to be clear the
FBI omitted that information from the
FISA applications and even used Carter's
connection to those Russian contacts as
evidence against him think of that for a
second they knew so it's like okay go
out there you're gonna have contact
you're gonna be informant with the
Russians and then afterward
gonna hang you out to dry and say what
was it informal with the Russians yeah
so here's why I am saying this
definitively that they create that they
falsified information you're the FBI
emailed the CIA to check if page was
working with them okay they confirmed
that page was a source that it the page
was a source but an FBI lawyer and then
I want to go to my lawyer he's a lawyer
an FBI lawyer actually altered the text
of the email to say he was not a source
to be clear okay it said was a source
initial FBI lawyer changed the text to
read not a sword not a source by the way
lawyer now under criminal investigation
oh how does that go half-asian lawyer
but can I make the claim that that is
falsifying evidence changing the word
yes
- no I mean yes here again here again is
the thing is how are they gonna try and
spin this and say you know it was just a
mistake oh you know just a low-level law
go for the FBI hit the delete button for
s.a.w
and then for some I accidentally typed
in n ot I don't know I spilled coffee in
the that's the last time I use a Dell
gateway I mean only gateway under
criminal investigation and I understand
the optics there's the court of public
opinion but this is a lot this is a lie
this seems like it would be something
that could be prosecuting these are the
types of things where you know we call
it the fruit of the poisonous tree is a
legal term right if you in in the common
parlance of like the Fourth Amendment
and other constitutional issues you have
to establish that if early in the chain
of creating evidence or taking certain
action by the government the government
takes wrong action right and the rest of
the information that comes from that the
fruit of the poisonous tree is now
poisoned as well right it's tainted and
here when you when you look at company
Comey understood the problem with that
that's why back in December 2018 he's
saying no no no don't worry the tree is
not poisoned everything's great we
fertilize it with great stuff except
they fertilized it with bull right
that's the problem
and then Eve tried to eat from it a
terrible instead
over and over now to be land you've
still angry about that huh I'm not she
wrote her autobiography on a Dell okay
since you can't this is also something
else cuz we have to get going people say
you know if you can't say something
better than the guy you said it before
you plagiarism the good thing is as a
host of a late-night show it's not
considered plagiarizing when I just run
a clip so let's just hear senator Ted
Cruz sum this up perfectly a lawyer at
the FBI fraudulent evidence alters an
email that is in turn used as the basis
for a sworn statement to the court that
the court relies on am i stating that
accurately that's correct
that is what occurred this is
unprecedented though this is
unprecedented to have these people in
these positions of power over as you've
said other good Americans who want to
serve the country according these
bureaus yeah in these wings of our of
our federal government to us obviously
one extent or another depending on which
division we're talking about right now
this is unprecedent for people wheeling
that kind of power to be complicit with
a media who don't care to do any
fact-checking right it's hard for us to
fact-check their claims because they
never lists them right that's why we try
to lose anywhere if i'm not mistaken i
think we have one more clip right okay
let's go to one last step and then go
there is such a range of conduct here
that is inexplicable and the answers we
got were not satisfactory that we're
left trying to understand how could all
these errors have occurred over a nine
month period or so among three teams
handpicked Hyatt one of the highest
profile from the highest profile case in
the FBI going to the very top of the
organization involving a presidential
campaign that is a great question and
that's why it begs could this all be an
accident how could these inexplicable
errors or at least they haven't been
explained yet all occur going up to the
very top of the organization was it just
a sloppy investigation or do all of
these errors it could just be a sloppy
investigation except when you account
for the fact here that all the errors
tilt in a certain direction one that's
anti President Trump can you let me ask
you this can you find anything to the
contrary in the last six months do you
ever get like you were to go back to
your saying remember the outrage over
bars review of the model report
demanded that he be ousted for his
conclude and obtained from the totality
of information available they saw that
his corruption at the highest level
possible but what about all of these
missteps or sometimes deliberate
inaccuracies in the most powerful
bureaus of government nothing and again
I think what's most important years
every time we get more information
it gets worse for the Democrats right
now in this whole these impeachment
proceedings that's why I think they're
handing Donald Trump the election I wish
this weren't going on because I think it
makes a mockery of our our entire not
only judicial system but the entire
system of American government
Schoolhouse Rock should be rolling over
and it's grave right now this is
absolutely unreal to me but like you
talked about with the IRS investigating
people the IRS being used as a tool from
Barack Obama to audit conservatives yeah
here's one thing to that I think because
you can audit a ham sandwich right
that's the old kind of adage people say
you can order a ham sandwich and find
something that's kind of true they just
there was a story someone just lost his
home because he was eight dollars on
their own property taxes right that's
scary to everybody where you go well
there's a certain amount of power where
the government can find something that
you've done wrong yeah if you're white
this is scary though because if they
don't find something that you've done
wrong they will make it up whether it's
Russian pissing prostitutes or changing
from did know about the steel dossier to
did not know about the steel dossier
this has gone beyond someone making a
mistake and a political enemy
capitalizing on it this has gone to the
most powerful wings of government
arguably in Washington DC now
deliberately fabricating or misleading
investigations for reasons of political
expediency it is terrifying and it sets
a terrifying precedent that we should
all be concerned about
mm-hmm you know what's in here it's just
water that's why they call it acting
what it actually smells garlicky there's
something wrong with the water I think
it's going through the ice maker and we
don't have we don't have the baking soda
in the fridge if you liked this video
subscribe hit notifications or just
check back every single day because we
upload a new video every single day this
was actually taken from the full show a
full hour show the way upload every
single Thursday click that right now go
watch the entire show if you don't want
to you don't you don't have to but if
you if you stop by you know just don't
bother me I'm gonna enjoy my garlic
water